let's go next to our caller
from the 616 area code who's calling
today from 616.
um hey david am i on yes you are who's
this
um um my name um my name is
it's john paul jones i'm from western
michigan and i just
um i just wanted to bring up a with a
bit of an interesting point i've been
thinking about
now hold on did you say your name is
john paul jones like the great bassist
the great fool uh isn't led zeppelin's
bassist john paul jones
um nothing no i'm i i'm not sure
the person i'm most familiar about with
that name is john paul tells the famous
historical sailor
i got it okay very good all right we'll
go on
um um i was just
um see i see about well
since about three months ago jesse
ventura announced that he was considered
running for
the green party presidential nominee
but eventually due to some sort of heat
a potential health problem he was forced
to
drop out but here's the thing i actually
think the situation right now
alex i was so bad where we could use a
green party cat they might actually
stand a chance
this year and i i'm thinking that if the
green
if holly hawking surrenders to the green
party nominee to jesse ventura so
his health problem has gone up away
wait hey the green party may actually
have a chance to win in some states or
or if things get so bad maybe even
even even the presidency um
no so john paul jones let me let me so
there is absolutely no chance that a
green party candidate wins a single
state it
there's no chance of that whatsoever joe
biden
is polling over 50 percent uh in
a huge number of states and nationally
and
really the only thing a green party
candidate might do
would be hand a state where it's close
to donald trump so a green party
candidate would not win a single state
and they certainly would not win the
presidency at this point
oh um yeah okay
okay um um okay i was just
well i would just think think about
thinking about that because yeah because
i think they're just so well i saw
nothing
in the u.s like right now that that
when things get bad people can usually
get desperate and
and well you know yes
you're thinking about all the right
things things are bad but uh
no the green party in this election
could only potentially
uh be a major major spoiler so let's
let's let's
let's get trump out of there let's get
joe biden and that's the next step all
right thank you my friend i appreciate
the call
we're gonna go to a very brief break
it's going to feel so short
but then we'll be back with more phone
calls so please don't hang up if you are
on hold because we are going
directly back to the phones